irrtümer panikmache verwirrung und jetzt
der umfrage schock immer wieder macht
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach verwirrende aussagen setzt
fragwürdige tweets ab und sorgt für
reichlich panik in der bevölkerung
bekommt er dafür jetzt die quittung sind
die bürger etwa genervt vom hin und her
minister
es wird immer verwirrter was er unser
gesundheitsminister der sozialdemokrat
karl lauterbach so von sich gibt mal
geht es in die eine richtung mal in die
andere
nun haben die deutschen anscheinend
genug nach einer von bild in auftrag
gegebenen insa umfrage fällt der einst
beliebteste politiker runter auf platz
zehn wie konnte es soweit kommen immer
öfter passiert es nachts wenn die sonne
untergegangen ist und die kirchturmuhr
mitternacht schlägt fängt es an dann
schickt er sie in die welt verwirrende
tweets wie hier
ein tweet der für ordentlich empörung
sorgt es geht um die geplante 3 monats
in frage demnach soll die vierte impfung
schon nach drei monaten ihre gültigkeit
verlieren wer nicht sofort nach impft
könnte ab oktober in der kneipe oder im
kino maske tragen oder einen test
vorliegen müssen lauterbach selbst sagt
das ist ein anreiz für die impfung doch
jetzt will der minister die regeln nicht
als empfehlung verstanden wissen als ein
journalist daran kritik übte haut
lauterbach am montagabend um 21 uhr 23
in die tasten glauben sie im ernst dass
menschen sich alle drei monate impfen
lassen um ohne maske in ein restaurant
gehen zu können
[Musik]
oder der fall vom juli dieses jahres
lauterbach warnte vor einer neuen corona
killer variante die sich schnell
übertragen und zu schweren verläufen
führe dabei weiß man inzwischen dass
selbst schwere corona verläufe nur noch
in seltenen fällen zum tode führen doch
lauterbach stand zu seiner panik
wortwahl manchmal muss man die dinge
beim namen nennen fakt ist kein experte
rechnet mit einer solchen variante auch
lauterbach spielte seine horror war
kürzlich runter nichts deutet darauf hin
dass eine killer variante uns im herbst
einholt
es ist nicht lauterbachs erste panik
prognose im november
2021 sagte er voraus dass mitte dezember
die intensivstation voll sein
tatsächlich brach die korona welle kurz
darauf die kliniken liefen nicht über
und die belegung der intensivstation
ging zurück lauterbach lag mit seiner
prognose wir einmal daniel
im sommer 2021 machte lauterbach im
wahlkampf nannte die korona impfung
nebenwirkungsfrei und das obwohl
nebenwirkungen infolge der kogit impfung
wissenschaftlich belegt sind nach
heftiger kritik von ärzten ruderte
minister lauterbach zurück sein
ministerium erklärte dass die impfungen
bei manchen menschen schwere
nebenwirkungen habe auch lauterbach
räumte ein dass es fälle mit sehr
schweren nebenwirkungen gebe
es war nicht das erste mal dass
lauterbach beim thema impfen für
verwirrung sorgte im sommer 2022
erklärte lauterbach im spiegel über den
vierten peaks er würde in absprache
natürlich mit dem hautarzt auch jüngeren
die impfung empfehlen lauterbach empfahl
also auch jüngeren menschen die vierte
impfung die stiko ist in ihrem bericht
aber deutlich dagegen gewesen als das
raus kam machte er karl lauterbach einen
rückzieher und wollte auf einmal nichts
davon wissen er erklärte ich habe nicht
gesagt für alle die vierte impfung
wie gesund ist der gesundheitsminister
für unser land wurde aus lauterbach am
ende klar
ich begrüße jetzt martinhagen fdp-chef
bayern hallo
ich grüße sie herr gefragt jetzt ganz
direkt haben die bürger die schnauze
voll von carlotta war
auf jeden fall zeigt ihre umfrage dass
der stern von karl lauterbach offenbar
sinkt schauen sie er ist ja nicht
minister geworden weil er in der spd als
ein politprofi gaal dass jemand der das
politische handwerk besser beherrscht
als andere sondern es deswegen minister
geworden weil er in corona winter 20 21
so ausgesprochen populär war er hat ein
gewisser weise die lust der leute an der
angst bedient die sehnsucht nach der
apokalypse er hat fortwährend gewarnt
und gemahnt jetzt ist der minister jetzt
muss er machen jetzt muss er handeln
jetzt muss er zeigen dass er den job
gewachsen ist und
da sind eben andere dinge gefragt und
sah gesundheitssystem hat riesige
herausforderungen die krankenkassen
denen droht jetzt ein defizit von 33
milliarden euro wir haben nach wie vor
eine pflegemangel in den krankenhäusern
also eigentlich viel zu tun für ein
gesundheitsminister zu mahnen zu warnen
und zu twittern und das reicht dann
nicht
gerade sehnsucht nach der apokalypse
also ich hatte die nicht woran man sich
das denn fest
ich hatte die auch nicht aber es gab
viele leute die ja ganz fasziniert waren
von dieser person karl lauterbach die
dauer kastler in den deutschen talkshows
uns immer erzählt hat wie fürchterlich
alles wird sie haben in ihrem bericht ja
selber gezeigt dass er häufig danebenlag
egal ob es um die killer varianten gegen
oder um andere prognosen aber die leute
hat das zumindest eine zeit lang
fasziniert diese faszination ist aber
glaube ich nicht von dauer sein das
lässt auch irgendwann nach und aus dem
grund jetzt offenbar der absturz in
umfragen ja nun verschärft deutschland
als einziges land im herbst winter
wieder die korona maßnahmen unsere
europäischen nachbarn die schütteln
schon ein bisschen mit den köpfen
frankreichs präsident immer nur marco
hat am wochenende die pandemie sogar als
beendet erklärt was sind denn ihre
schlimmsten befürchtungen für den
anstehenden herbst winter in unserem
land
also ich würde mal abwarten ob die
europäischen nachbarn wirklich komplett
ohne krone regeln durch diesen winter
gehen wir haben den letzten jahren ja
schon immer gemerkt dass in den kalten
monaten die lage noch einmal
angespannter wird als im sommer da würde
ich noch nicht sagen dass wir in
deutschland auf ein sonderweg unterwegs
sind wichtig war dass wir für den sorten
hat den sonderweg beendet haben dass die
fdp gegen den widerstand von karl
lauterbach und auch gegen den widerstand
zb der grünen aber auch der opposition
der union durchgesetzt hat dass wir die
rückkehr zur normalität wagen es hat
sich als vollkommen richtig erwiesen und
jetzt haben wir für den herbst
bundesweite regeln die ja auch sehr
maßvoll sind die sich auf den schutz
lokaler gruppen fokussieren die masken
pflicht in krankenhäusern und
altenheimen zum beispiel aber wir haben
eben auch gesagt wenn unerwartet die
lage nochmals richtig verschärft wenn
die kritische infrastruktur gefährdet
ist nicht weil so viele leute sterben
oder ins krankenhaus müssen aber einfach
weil so viele leute erkranken
dann haben die länder noch mal die
möglichkeit für zusätzliche maßnahmen
das sind nicht mehr die maßnahmen die
wir aus der merkel zeit kennen also
nicht mehr locker uns nicht nur
schulschließungen nicht mehr kontakt
beschränkungen und auch nicht mehr der
ausschluss ungeimpfter vom öffentlichen
leben sondern das sind maßvolleren
maßnahmen ich hoffe aber dass wir auch
die nicht brauchen werden und ich hoffe
dass die landesregierungen vor einem
verantwortungsvollen mit diesen
instrumenten die in der bunten zur
verfügung steht stellt dh die fdp wird
sich knallhart gegen einen weiteren
lockdown wären
es gibt keine rechtsgrundlage für einen
weiteren lockdown wollen wir haben die
epidemische lage nationaler tragweite ja
im vergangenen november beendet und es
gibt auch überhaupt keine notwendigkeit
für einen neuen locker und jedenfalls
nicht mit dem virus varianten die wir
momentan haben ich hielte es auch für
falsch wieder zum beispiel die masken
pflicht in schulen einzuführen da kann
nicht alle landesregierungen nur davor
warnen wir sollten uns wirklich auf den
schutz der wohl mehr allen gruppen der
risikogruppen fokussieren die sitzen
nicht in den schulen sondern die sitzen
zb in altenheimen und krankenhäusern
[Musik]